hey guys Ryan right here hey guys how a
man's are here we're gonna check out
from top training today fried real-life
killers who inspired horror movies with
some of the sick and twisted horror
movies that are out it's shocking to
know that some were in fact based on
truth hang tight as we take you through
some seriously twisted real horror
stories born in Louisville USA and
raised through hatred and abuse
Daniel Harold began his spree of terror
in 1990 when his father failing to claim
the life he would cost his father and
ear and I just a few short months later
Daniel would go on to kill eight people
five of which were college students he
would then proceed to mutilate sexually
pose and finally engage in sexual acts
with his victims corpses he would go on
to be the inspiration behind the scream
movies film director bryan bertino would
draw influence for his movie The
Strangers owners of the Doosan family
broke into the house of director Roman
Polanski found his wife Sharon Tate and
fourth her friends inside they would be
bound together and stabbed multiple
times with the word Pig smeared across
the house with the blood of their
victims like the movie the group was
unable to call for help as their phone
lines had been severed Adolfo was born
in Miami Florida where he was a known
drug dealer cult leader and serial
killer after he was rejected in joining
a powerful crime family known as the cow
sadhas' seven family member leaders
would be found shortly thereafter with
their fingers ears brains and spines
removed using this notoriety Adolfo
would join into a new cartel the
Hernandez brothers where he would be
responsible for numerous other sadistic
and ritualistic murders the 2007 movie
borderland was loosely based upon his
exploits the inspiration behind the cult
horror films psycho and Texas Chainsaw
Massacre
there's Dean's mother a strict and
devout Lutheran would keep him refined
to the house preaching that all women
were prostitutes and instruments of the
devil he would kidnap and butcher young
women in which he claimed reminded him
of his own mother and crafted furniture
from their flesh all these things were
lampshades made from faces and noses
belts made from female nipples boxes
filled with female genitals dismembered
body parts in sacks filled dressed
corpses of young women and bowls made
from polished skulls
escaping death through the plea of
insanity Edie would spend the rest of
his days in a maximum-security facility
for the criminally insane until he would
die of heart failure at 77 years old
kidnapper rapist and murderer of
numerous female victims during the 1970s
Ted Bundy aka the very definition of
heartless evil was the main inspiration
for the character Hannibal Lecter from
Silence of the Lambs as well as other
films Ted would use his charisma to lure
women into trusting him until he had
them in a secluded area he would murder
his victim and come back some time later
to perform sexual acts on the corpses of
over 30 women subscribe please subscribe
well man Ted Bundy though I know was
like I've seen like documentaries about
him how he was this really charming dude
so I thought I reckon psyche okay so it
was Christian Bale you know yeah some of
those people was really charming you
never suspect you know that's what a
psychopath is like you don't expose you
at that they're really normal people
from the outside the stories of people
who like kill their parents or something
those tend to really disturb me which is
worse when the parent kills a kid for
sure
but when someone kills their own parent
it's like oh man like the one that
inspired their saying that inspired the
scream story
I don't remember not it from the fact
that he killed his dad but I know it
caught
unlike his ear and stuff it's
interesting because some of these movies
are pointing out are so [ __ ] popular
and so well known and it's hard to make
its comparison its creepier and scary
and kind of morally not right when you
think about how these huge franchise
horror films are stemmed from a basis
and reality of people who actually were
killed so it kind of makes you go well
it's not just entertainment at this
point er they're they're getting an
entertainment franchise off of the
deaths of real people I've always wanted
that you know we can all watch scary
movies of people getting like botched up
murdered whatever but right when it
comes down to like an actual documentary
or something that is true like we all
have much different reactions then we
were watching more of them but then
again it's kind of like I'm pretty sure
it's not that far off from the visuals
what they show and movies because they
do try and make it as realistic as
possible by looking at actual photos or
actual footage it's not weird that we
don't have that reaction but I will say
that like I've seen some incredibly
gruesome films that will just gross me
the [ __ ] out but I could see something
that's on a technically minimal scale
compared to the Gorna movie but if it's
real life that will disturb me so it's
so it's weird because like a movie was
gonna be so gory but there's the Loews
awareness of fiction involved like they
were showing the person who inspired a
Leatherface and psycho Norman Bates like
the couch is made of faces and stuff and
like I I didn't know that dude went all
out like that I've heard of him and
stuff but I didn't know he was that
[ __ ] insane the movies go way worse
but seeing a real photo of that like is
just oh like it gets it just makes it
all the more real and messed up and you
know the Charles Manson story inspired
the perfect strangers that Manson story
I've always found pretty interesting
like a lot of these serial killer
stories I gotta admit you know like I'm
not for serial killers at all but there
is a fascination to that yeah I watched
a documentary and the whole Charles
Manson thing and not I found it super
fascinating but it was just kind of like
I don't when I got to when he did end up
killing them it just kind of like I was
like how did it get there yeah I mean
Charles Manson is such a especially
nowadays such a crazy [ __ ] person
like he's just like out of his mind all
the blame tends to go to him but he was
dealing with a cult of followers so that
a long walk there's a lot of people and
this this cult that was so fun her
actually did anything he just told
everyone he knew how to manipulate and
stuff yeah he Nick that's a scary part
definitely people did I go and kill
someone yeah he knew how to warm our he
knew how to warp minds and stuff and I
don't think he's ever fully admitted to
the truth of his actions I think he's
always kind of denied it no I didn't do
it other people for me did it yeah and
he'll sometimes deny that he even told
people to do it yeah as a fun video it's
really fun I love watching top trending
yeah yeah someone tries to kill you just
let me know okay I'll text the police do
they receive text messages you sure
there's like apps reading call 911 like
you can do it on your someone needs an
app to call 9-1-1 well you know if
you're walking on money I want to be
super obvious like I'm calling everyone
guys behind me I don't know what AB
Sakhalin I three digits there's an actor
like follows you home like it makes sure
that you get home safely and if you like
stray away then it calls 9-1-1 for you
mm or if you feel threatened me press a
button I'm gonna app that I could put up
against my balls and they could tell me
my sperm count why do you care to know
the amount in case Frank is ovulating
we're trying to have a baby
you do know that great job yeah I just
decided after watching this video that
we're gonna try to have a baby
I realized bringing a baby into this
world would be a great idea anyway guys
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out salamander Sally's channel
where it's just as dark and haunting as
this video that we just saw I'm trying
to give you good promotions good
promotions and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope Jean Jean Carlos Olivier era
Miranda you need a new [ __ ] in hi
guys
I'd like a shout out please I'm a
Brazilian fan and hopefully not the only
one why do you care I discovered your
channel recently and you guys are now a
part of my day
Ryan is a force of life that is just a
life all to watch and Jerry is okay just
kidding Jerry is cool but I still think
you should do negative reviews when the
movies are bad if Jerry is known to like
a lot of [ __ ] movies a Jean Jean
Carlos Olivia a Miranda dude listen your
name too long if you want to be a
celebrity no one's gonna want to
pronounce your whole [ __ ] name you
got a short in it a little bit I don't
exactly know a Brazilian people look
like so let's see what you look like he
kind of looks like Chris Tucker he looks
black he doesn't look Brazilian to me
Oh Brazilians are dark-skinned like
Hispanics but they can be dark it's
Brazilian a real race uh yeah they're
from Brazil
what's Brazil oh that's where um that's
where Blanca
from street fighters from the big green
guy with crazy orange hair the Beast or
so you're like Blanca
hey no Charlotte Olivier I'm gonna in
the booth do you know what Blanca looks
like Sally oh no this is called Blanca
reaction yeah like the Hulk in the 80s
or something yeah no that's Brazilian
right there okay watch you put the two
together they look exactly
they look exactly the same don't get at
this game I'm good at this game